bitte bleib stehen einmal mit mit der
handlung und schenken ist daher tragen
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute spielen wir crazy girls und martin
schmid und heinrich familien oder damit
nehmen kann und heute spielen wir eine
entschuldigung redeschwall am anfang
ich mag ich auch gar nicht wenn leute so
die kamera schreien aber was ich sagen
wollte leute heute spielen wir eine
version von minecraft die wir schon
länger nicht mehr gemacht haben und zwar
heute wieder das format xy sagt und
heute ist xy max die letzten folgen
hatte ich ja mit luca remscheid peak
nada aufgenommen
heute ist wieder max dabei natürlich
wenn er hier im haus ist mit mir liegt's
ja nur auf der hand dass wir quasi mal
kann ich sagt aufnehmen und ja du darfst
quasi heute bestimmen du hast vier lukat
ihr letztes auch viel hass auf 44
gelegenheiten einen befehl zu geben ganz
klassisch vier befehle geben in der
ganzen runde und ich muss machen was du
sagst das heißt leute weiß es noch nicht
kennt wenn max zum beispiel jetzt sagt
jany sagt wirft eine lagerbox weg dann
wäre ich nie weg wenn er sagt seine
rüstung auslöst sich theoretisch die
rüstung ausziehen
wer natürlich nicht so cool aber das
einzige was er nicht darf ist das wie
bring dich um oder verlass die runde zu
sagen dass das ist verboten
das ist das theoretisch ist das erlaubt
war sehr unruhig aber erst mal ne frage
sollen wir mal die farm fahrer
überspringen oder willst du während der
farben phase vielleicht schon was
raushauen beim einkaufen vielleicht
alles klar okay also wir fahren wir
zielen die sämtlich materialien ab und
dann sehen wir uns wieder wenn wir alles
geholt haben sechseinhalb stunden später
ist richtet es riecht fein
möglichkeit noch mal singen nicht fürs
video sich damit persönlich bei so viel
so leute wenn man es alles geholt wir
haben hier schon elf gold 11 smaragd
zwei lucky blogs homoki apples nicht so
schlechten feuerzeug also ich warte
jetzt nicht darauf dass du immer sagen
ich spiele jetzt einfach
und weil die sache ist ja dass max und
ich so wenn wir da nie sagt aufnehmen so
ein bisschen gegner sind
ich versuche natürlich noch nicht 100
für euch zu spielen max versuchten
fixies alter mensch nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend leute böses wort
er wusste dass marek zwei schwerter hat
wenn man auf neid doch hat man ja dass
kool aid kit zwei schwer das heißt du
kannst quasi mit dem schärfer 2 in die
rhone staaten theoretisch wenn du nicht
fucking nehme sich der gliederfüßer
bekommst schon wieder ein böses wort
über teile wie wärs granie sagt du
brauchst nur das flames und ein bogen
die stadt das ist drei jungs hatten zwei
ja das sagt kani aber als ob plötzlich
dass sie kein schwert benutzen
doch du darfst deine flames ort benutzen
dann rennst du bearbeitet mit dem bogen
ultimate fighter einer axt und benutzt
neben ihn zu finishen aber die axt ihre
fünf angriff schaden aber kraftwerke
junge leute das wird richtig schwierig
jeder im dorf von noch gesagt
gegenspieler ja du hast recht was recht
ist es trotzdem sehr knackig aber wir
können es probieren was ist denn wenn
ich den ersten gegner getötet hat da
darfst du einfach sind dann darf ich
weiter kämpfen ja aber nur etwas anderes
wegwerfen wegwerfen kann sagt weg sie
reinigen
okay leute könnt schaffen dass so viele
goldene äpfel und soja ich habe ab
theoretischen proporz aber ich muss mich
auf jeden fall zurückhalten so okay
leute wir dürfen uns einfach vor
da ist direkt du wirst du gleich zwei
und das video mit schwert geht nicht
kaputt machen werde ist mir die aktie
tags als ob ich das schaffe der frist
saugut endlich wieder der frist vor
alter wir haben geholt
jetzt kannst du schnell in schweren und
da ist champions bei hatte er sogar v.li
kaum schlechter der gekämpft ja ohne
hätten fucking axtmann dürftig sagte zur
fucking zitat lukaku stärke 2 bogen
wahrscheinlich auch welt war der op wie
habe ich den geholt man okay es geht
weiter den hole ich mir auch mal ganz
entspannt drei wünsche hast du quasi
noch frei ich bin auch schon ein begriff
die nächstens formulieren uns aber finde
ich so die player heads bisschen
barbarisch wenig die letzte wir mal
schön kann man viele sachen gekauft
ich finde du solltest netto mindestens
zwei von ihnen die du aktuell besitzt
verschenken du hast ja drei stück
verschenken wahrscheinlich den anderen
tv datteln so einfach ich meine man muss
auch noch ein bisschen bisschen
uneigennützig sein in so einer runde
insider
was sie wollten mich fängt man kann ich
etwas schenken einfach zu werfen
schaltet dann wieder schmecken einfach
mal schön die player hat mit denen sich
die übelsten sachen kaufen können mit
einem darfst du dir selbst noch was
holen drei also einen darf ich einsetzen
erklärte drei stück ja wenn man ich kann
mir auch jetzt immer eine schwertfirm
upgraden alter einer dragon schock mich
nicht genommen shop eigentlich der wille
zustehen ok warte dann gehen wir hier
über die ecke muss dem nächsten gegner
den du siehst das ding schenk mal auf
den davor nicht schlagend mache ich
manchmal also ich würde und packte und
dann überhaupt diese zwei herzlich
verschenken hatte ich nicht mehr hetzen
die drei städte tallinn links ist der
hit war gerade in blau erinnert rennen
schema des voll aggro nehmt alle händler
mit dieser fässer dieser teppich wollten
spektakel ist ein bus hatte wo sich ein
hatte wenn du wenn du den gegner sie ist
ja ja sag mir bescheid dann gehe ich
sofort hin
ok kann sagt bescheid sagt bescheid
ok-chef 3 haben wir power 3 auch jetzt
aber den leuten ja was gut ja voll ist
erste gegner wartet
mit der hand und schenken müsse daher
tragen noch einmal erinnert werden
wieder glaube ich eine kurve alles auf
gesehen wird hat ist ja irre
also es gibt noch zwei spieler da ist
auch noch einer geht es ist ein anderer
vielleicht wird er die köpfe ihrer op
wohnungsbau in der mitte stand hier da
kommen wir mit das wäre ja wohl
rechtlich richtig erlebt ihr herz mit
jetzt jetzt hab ich wieder richtig
spielen ob das ziel bedeutete zwei
wünsche hast du noch leben aber nur ein
leben noch drei spieler weißer watte was
ist das mein bruder ist die schweiz
gehört viel öl da von dem jetzt was
geschenkt das jetzt dauerhaft einen
heute zeigst um frieden und darf sie
nicht mehr an drei weißt du das nur noch
den anderen greifend erst dann kannst du
den jahren greifen hieß es ist ein
verbot erst jetzt hast du den anderen
reifen auf wo ist der andere muss andere
hatte den kann sich auch über das ein
trecker entfernen oder nicht die junge
das ist so los ist jetzt einfach
dringend ein kumpel
das ist einfach band war locker easy und
mache ich denn hier wusste andere gegner
ich hoffe nicht
ja sonst einfach bahn aber niemand vom
lokal schaut niemand vom high peak city
meine videos niemals nie ich glaube die
haben ihre ohren auf dem weg sein
kollege alvin irgendwas alvin xd und
neve hat das ist als ob er wieder
angreift verhalten du ratte mit ein
wenig glück - mit der hand jetzt du
kleiner schlingel hast du hast du dann
lwl angegriffen
hast du keinen angegriffen allen ernstes
das ist fakt wenn man finger weg von mir
bekommst du mit mir zu tun wenn du den
angreifer mit meinem power fünf bogen
hast du passt mal auf ja dass eltern
wussten was lord of the club von diehl
herr interfax ok das bedeutet im
umkehrschluss musste jetzt selbst
irgendwie bestrafen
sämtliche hoch mit den 36 irgendwie auf
15 blöcke und dann sprichst du runter
gar nicht sagt aber in alter darf ich am
lg damaschin 45 67 ist es ein letzter
wunsch acht neun zehn elf nein
wie passt schon fast schon oma sagt
dieser sack erschießt sie einfach runter
und schießt du das nicht verboten aber
heruntergeschossen soll wieder aufbauen
musste ja ich meine power 5 werten dass
technologie 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12 13
14 15 und runter springen kann keinen
gemacht wollte ich es voll davon dass da
hab ich ja ok ok 5 verloren somit mit
äpfeln regelt mit nächsten gold war ein
okay
hast du etwas gutes band 4 jetzt bin ich
habe ein kleines stofftier das ist nicht
mein kollege ja aber die sind letzten
zwei mutter fanny sagt singen ein
liebeslied für dich oh sinken
du bist der beste crazy world spieler